for those that fled
now coming back to see what's left of
the life they left behind for some
Devastation what matters is what I'm
holding right here okay
it's just material stuff
retirement our own life
we're going to rebuild 23 years
some homes simply blown or washed away
don't appear to have any windows
broken for others I'm feeling great the
house is still here and those that
stayed now recounting terrifying hours
so the top of the roof just cake slapped
in on me and my three kids and my
grandson my daughter is pregnant she's
five months pregnant so she was laying
on the side of the bed where the roof
was coming in and it fell on her but she
was I was able to pull her out of it
idalia came ashore as a category 3
hurricane in Florida the state suffering
the worst of the storm but it hit a
sparsely populated area and so far no
fatalities it continued as a tropical
storm through Georgia and the Carolinas
in South Carolina a storm surge of
almost three meters too high for a flood
wall in Charleston Water rushed into the
historic downtown one man was killed in
Georgia by a fallen tree but considering
this area has not seen a storm this
strong in 127 years the general feeling
is it could have been so much worse as
of 6 a.m today there are approximately
146 thousand power outages reported
across the state but power is being
restored quickly thus far 420 000
accounts that lost power during the
storm have been restored still this
storm spanning more than 560 kilometers
when it came ashore left behind a huge
area of Destruction one that will take
months and for some years to recover
from Patty culhane Al Jazeera